[Music]
honor Markov works as a quality
inspector for a company called normal
distributors the company has
manufacturing plants in five cities on a
routinely conduct surprise inspections
at each site to check for abnormalities
she flies from city to city randomly
through airports with direct connecting
flights every time she performs an
inspection she stamps her logbook then
she selects the next city she will fly
to randomly from all available
connecting flights with equal
probabilities the five cities are
average Mount faysville continue aah
police discreet town and East
vandermonde not all of these cities are
connected via direct flights to each
other for example there was a direct
flight from average Monta base ville but
not from average mont to east
vandermonde in the long run which city
do you think she will spend the most
time in a average mont B faysville C
continue aah police D discrete town e
east vandermonde F about equal among the
five cities or G it depends on which
city she starts out in today Anna is in
bays ville she uses a spinner to pick
randomly from all available cities with
equal probabilities faysville is a major
hub and has direct connections to all
the other cities the spinner lands on
average Mont so that is her next stop
[Music]
just another average day in average
month after she finishes her inspection
it's time to choose the third stop let's
see where she lands next
raise well again wait do I keep ending
up in bass Ville now it's time for her
to pick the next stop oh great
he's vandermonde I haven't been there in
ages East vandermonde is more remote and
only has flights back to base Ville so
she will definitely go back to Bay's
Ville next why am I even bothering with
this silly spinner if I keep doing this
I wonder what fraction of my time will I
end up spending in base ville the
process that anna is following is an
important example of a Markov chain the
Markov property means that at each time
point determining the next city that
honor will go to depends only on where
she currently is and the randomness of
her spinner given the present the future
is independent of the past this is a
form of memorylessness given her current
location her past history is irrelevant
for predicting where she will go next to
answer honest question let's consider
the following problem in the long run as
Anna continues this random process what
percentage of her time will she spend in
each city let's plot this after various
numbers of trips we have 1 bar for each
city and the height of each bar
indicates the percentage of time Anna
has spent in that city overall in our
simulation here is how the distribution
looks
[Music]
[Music]
at first the plot was fluctuating a lot
but now it seems to have stabilized the
distribution it has stabilized to is
called the stationary distribution of
the Markov chain we are showing one
particular run of the simulation but
Ana's process will always converge to
the same stationary distribution no
matter which city she starts out in it
turns out that the percentage of time
honest spends in a city is proportional
to its number of connections for example
Bayes Ville has four connections an East
vandermonde only has one so on a visits
Bayes Ville four times as often as East
vandermonde in the long run the network
structure is the key to determining the
stationary distribution
you
you